carnegie mellon university has put
together a brand new initiative which we
call brain hub to address the large
challenges that are associated with
understanding both the basic science
associated with brain function but also
the relationship between brain function
and various kinds of diseases including
autism Alzheimer's disease and
Parkinson's disease when you open your
eyes and you see the world laid out in
front of you how is it that the brain
has constructed meaning and precision of
the visual world so rapidly from the
course information that it receives from
the eye and the research that I do is to
try and understand how this is achieved
what is it
that the brain is doing what are the
mechanisms what are the psychological
what are the neural mechanisms that give
rise to this meaningful coherent unified
perception with such rapidity there is
an additional factor that has really
enabled us to make progress in this
domain and that has to do with the
development of analytic and technical
methodologies machine learning
engineering statistical analyses in
order to be able to cope with the
enormity of the big data that we get out
of the human brain and also out of the
more basic neuroscience research brain
hub is breaking onto the world stage in
a number of ways including through
formal affiliations with a host of
international partners and a number of
local partners including the University
of Pittsburgh with whom we've had a very
long association and so there is
tremendous urgency for us right now to
use these different methods to use our
expertise to understand the brain and
its alteration so that we can really
begin to address these diseases that we
see in humans and bring about some kind
of change for the good
you